zone europe / sensations
bonsoir et bienvenue dans un europe /
sensation une émission spéciale
consacrée à notre alimentation et la
lutte contre l'obésité un numéro
enregistré au parlement européen de
strasbourg est réalisée en association
avec tv 78 voici le sommaire de ce
nouveau numéro
est tout d'abord on va s'intéresser aux
étapes du projet europe à table
coordonné par la fédération française
des maisons de l'europe dans le cadre de
la présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne direction pour
commencer les yvelines sous une robe
je suis christine colleville
coordinatrice à la maison de l'europe
des yvelines à saint germain en laye
cette visite aujourd'hui nous permettait
d'aller nous rendre compte d'une
exploitation agricole en agriculture
raisonnée à côté de la queue en yvelines
dans les yvelines et nous avons pu
découvrir le meut le moulin de moisson à
la ferme de moisan cette visite prend
effet en fait dans le cadre d'un projet
qui s'appelle europe à table et qui est
porté par la fédération française des
maisons de l'europe fédération à
laquelle nous adhérons en tant que
maison de l'europe des yvelines et ce
projet et
il y a environ 12 maisons de l'europe
qui contribuent jusqu'à la fin de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne moi j'ai trouvé les jeunes
lycéens très curieux de connaître mieux
le processus de récolte du blé le
processus dans ce mage de la graine de
blé et puis aussi toute la partie
fabrication de la farine puis
fabrication du pain puisque tout se fait
sur place ici à la ferme de moisan et
donc ils nous ont étonnés par leur et
leurs questions assez précis sur sur des
processus et sur la qualité des produits
et qu'ils sont réalisés
je suis madame blanc despina professeur
de cuisine certifiait j'enseigne ce
matin aux mises à niveau c'est des
étudiants qui ont fait un bac général ou
un bac technologique
mais d'une autre spécialité et qui
intègre notre lycée pour préparer donc
l'année prochaine en bts management de
l'hôtellerie restauration
c'est très important les circuits courts
donc avoir une démarche locavore en
restauration
c'est tout à fait dans l'air du temps
c'est très important pour le
développement durable on est maintenant
amener à respecter mais c'est très
important aussi pour la traçabilité et
la qualité du produit
c'est un produit qui n'est pas arrivé à
nos assiettes
de l'autre au bout de la terre mais
c'est un produit qui vient peut-être de
l'île de france
de normandie on a beaucoup produit qui
vient de normandie de bretagne
on essaye de respecter dans la mesure du
possible et puis l'ile-de-france à elle
peut nous fournir des très bons produits
des crémeries des très bons légumes et
même des viandes on n'a pas mis à 100%
un circuit court le cav or dans un rayon
de 200 km mais on est dans cette
démarche qui se met en place et
respecter aussi la saisonnalité c'est
très important tous les professeurs même
si on aime des fois faire les cuisines
de la méditerranée avec des courgettes
des aubergines des tomates s'est finie
en hiver on ne commande plus ces
produits on va respecter donc la saison
aussi c'est comme ça aussi d'ailleurs
qu'on peut respecter également les
circuits courts on veut pas voir des
tomates de la région parisienne fall in
vino pour le faire je suis vice
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines en charge des ruralités et je
suis très heureuse d'accompagner des
élèves
visitez cette structure la cic va leur
viande qui est un atelier de
transformation
situe à gaz rend à côté de rambouillet
dans le sud yvelines qui transforme des
produits locaux qui viennent des
éleveurs en grande partie blinois et qui
est vraiment un outil structurant est
essentielle au maillage de notre
territoire qui permet
de mettre en place des logiques de
circuits courts et de valorisation de
nos productions agricoles je m'appelle
antoine bellouet je suis en deuxième
année de bts mhr au lycée hôtelier de
saint quentin en yvelines alors là le
but de la vie d'aujourd'hui on a visité
un endroit où ils découpent les
volailles ou ouimet temps
ancolie où il fabrique des saucissons y
mettre un peu en place la viande c'est
intéressant parce que déjà on a vu comme
lyon comment il développé tout ce qui
est locavorisme c'est à dire les
circuits coup on a appris comment ils
mettaient en place de quelle manière
nous avons invité l'école hôtelière de
saint quentin en yvelines qui est un
partenaire de notre projet europa table
projet fédéral sur toute la france et
qui va permettre à un binôme de l'école
hôtelière de participer à un concours
national en mars prochain louvier en
normandie nous avons pu organiser une
visite d'exploitation à la ferme de la
une hier ici à son chant ainsi qu'à
l'atelier valeur à gaz errants et nous
avons pu rencontrer d'une par
l'exploitant de cette ferme qui nous a
expliqué le fonctionnement de la ferme
et ses spécificités avec l'exploitation
de la production de volailles et à
l'atelier de gaz et rend il s'agit de
l'atelier de transformation de ces
volailles afin de pouvoir
élaborés les produits
qu'ils soient directement à la mise à la
vente ensuite par le biais des
producteurs moi je m'appelle lucas van
sant et je suis en deuxième année de bts
au lycée hôtelier de 50 ans ici on avait
tout l'exploitation
au niveau des des volailles qui
produisit
il n'en montrait tous les to les silos
qu'ils avaient tous les toutes les
machines tous les appareils vu que c'est
beaucoup automatisé maintenant nous a
montré comment ça marche et par avoir à
l'époque en fait c'est intéressant parce
que c'est beaucoup de produits qu'on
travaille nous soit au lycée ou en stage
et du coup bas savoir d'où ça provient
comment c'est fait c'est important pour
nous du coup souvent on aller par
exemple en termes de poulets par exemple
on a beaucoup les poulets bas soit
entier soit on les vide on sait pas
vraiment comment c'est fait comment
s'est nourrie comment ils s'en occupent
toute l'année et c'est donc assez
intéressante
sous une robe
et maintenant avec océane danielli
directrice de la fédération française
des maisons de l'europe retour sur le
concours europa table organisé en
normandie bonjour je m'appelle au cn
danielli et je suis la directrice de la
fédération française des maisons de
l'europe donc le trophée europe hattab
qui est le concours qui s'est déroulé
aujourd'hui est la finalité d'un gros
projet qui a duré environ un an
ce projet se divise en trois phases il
ya une première phase où les maisons de
l'europe ont
sensibilisé leurs établissements
partenaires à des thématiques liées à
l'alimentation l'environnement
je pense à de la ferme à la table je
pense à
la pac et c'est des sujets qui lie
l'europe l'agriculture et l'alimentation
différents voilà différents ateliers ont
été mises en place au sein des
établissements et par la suite il y à
une deuxième phase de sélection au sein
des établissements de binômes qui puisse
concourir lors de cette troisième phase
trophée europe à table qui a lieu
maintenant fin mars à louviers dans les
grandes lignes c'était lié
donc des aliments a obéi gp normand donc
locaux avec une thématique européenne
tout ça en cuisine en ayant conscience
de voilà de différents critères comme
les déchets
prendre locale prendre de saison voilà
tout ce qui est lié en fait au
développement durable
et au futur de l'alimentation saône
europe
focus à présent sur les jeunes
finalistes de l'édition 2022 du trophée
europa table bay nous c'est marie et
louise mendjeli d'apcher du lycée
hôtelier on a fait un plat aujourd'hui à
pour le concours aux tables qui est
basée à base du bar qui est cuit à
l'état c'est à dire sur la peau avec la
d'herbe ihringen de sésame on a
travaillé aussi le bulot en tartare
croquant avec des légumes croquants de
la pomme du fenouil des carottes
betteraves etc on a accompagné aussi
avec une mousseline de chou-fleur
safrané et ensuite on a travaillé une
recette de l'europe avec la route chimie
qui est dans cette italienne c'est une
boule croustillante avec un intérieur
crémeux et au lieu de remplacer le
risotto pas du jury par les tout
simplement les lentilles vertes du
larzac qui a encore un produit de chez
nous au pommeau de normandie du cou et à
la pomme être aimé qu'on sente bien en
normandie la créme
saône robe sûr sensation
l'alimentation une des priorités de
l'union européenne comme le souligne
ferran tarradellas espuny chef de la
communication à la représentation en
france de la commission européenne il y
avait beaucoup de chose de politique
européenne que sur le lit et la
gastronomie alors c'est le concours pour
moi c'était un façon de mettre en valeur
les motos de l'union européenne qui
s'est remis dans la diversité
alors il avait en déverser des pluies de
différents endroits il avait en la
diversité et créativité des gens qui ont
fait des concours mais on a mis en
valeur d'autres choses comme par exemple
à
la durabilité il avait des gens qui
voulaient rien j'étais et profiter tout
le matériel pour faire des choses il
avait bon le travail bien fait à un mode
de vie
défendre les produits avec dénomination
d'origine européenne
ça c'est une chose qu'on peut exporter
après et ils avaient l'égalité hommes
femmes on essayait de faire des couples
mixtes là il y avait beaucoup de valeur
que je crois que ça me en 197 concours
en est que c'est aussi une façon de
fêter notre diversité et notre unité
européen effectivement cette année cette
année unique pour différentes raisons
d'un côté c'est l'année
européenne de la jeunesse ont fait
remettre en valeur les jeunes qui elle
se faire beaucoup pendant la crise
sanitaire c'est aussi l'année de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui ces deux concours a lieu
en france c'est pas par chance et on met
en valeur effectivement la stratégie de
la ferme à la table que ceux qui ont
baissé à voir une nourriture plus saine
mais qui bénéficient les agriculteurs et
les producteurs mais aussi les
consommateurs qui finalement ils vont
avoir une meilleure santé grâce à ce
qu'il maniait
sont en europe l'invité tic
une alimentation saine une agriculture
raisonnée moins de pesticides
l'eurodéputée michèle rivasi sera mon
invité je reçois aujourd'hui michèle
rivasi bonjour bush ou alors vous êtes
eurodéputés membres du groupe des verts
alliance libre européenne membre
suppléant de la commission de
l'environnement de là santé publique et
de la sécurité alimentaire alimentaires
alors en mars dernier pour faire face
aux conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
la commission européenne a présenté
différentes mesures pour augmenter la
production agricole et garantir la
sécurité alimentaire dans l'union
européenne mais également au niveau
mondial alors en avant d'en venir à
l'utilisation des pesticides déjà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner votre
sentiment sur ce premier volet bah
écoutez j'ai pas compris la position de
la commission est notamment aussi les
états membres parce qu'en fait ils
profitent de la guerre en ukraine
par les russes pour dire regardez il ya
l'augmentation prix il ya des pays qui
vont
avoir des difficultés pour
s'approvisionner donc ce qu'a fait
la politique agricole commune européenne
par le green deal eh ben on va faire
sauter tout ce qui touche à
l'environnement parce que il y avait 4 %
des terres qui devait être mis en
jachère
et dans ces terres là on devait pas
utiliser des pesticides et les syndicats
majoritaires au niveau des agriculteurs
ont profité de ça pour dire il faut
augmenter la production mais c'est pas
un problème de production c'est un
problème que il ya eu une augmentation
de prix d'ailleurs qui était avant la
guerre en ukraine parce qu'il ya des
problèmes de spéculation parce que
il ya un problème aussi de distribution
et que la guerre n'a fait qu'aggraver le
problème mais
le sujet c'est pas qu'il ya un manque de
production il faut la distribuer et
surtout il faut que les prix
n'augmentent pas pour que des pays comme
les pays du maghreb comme par exemple
l'egypte mais le sénégal le yémen etc
qui utilisent énormément de céréales
puisse
faire en sorte à ce que ça soit
abordable vous prêtez régulièrement les
le poids des lobbys au parlement
européen là vous pensez que les lobbys
profite de la gare en ukraine au bras
c'est vraiment c'est l'agrobusiness qui
profitent de la guerre en ukraine pour
d'une part spéculer et puis d'autre part
casser le fait qu'on avait obtenu
quelques mesures environnementales pour
diminuer la quantité de pesticides pour
développer par exemple de l'agriculture
biologique puisque dans le plan il y
avait de la ferme à la fourchette il y
avait au moins 25% de terre en bio il y
avait moins d'utilisation des intrants
et on voit bien les intrants c'est quoi
ces les engrais or on est très dépendant
justement des engrais qui viennent à la
fois du bélarus mais aussi de russie par
rapport au gaz et donc il profite de ça
pour dire il faut faire sauter ces
jachères et il faut augmenter la
production certains eurodéputés salue
l'action des lobbys au parlement
européen qu'est ce que vous avez à leur
dire mais quel lobby de quel lobby on
parle si on parle des lobbys qui sont
pour augmenter une agriculture intensive
justement qui nous rendent dépendant des
pays comme la russie par son gaz ou
d'autres pays je vois pas quel est
l'intérêt
nous on a toujours défendu une
agriculture si vous voulez qu'il soit la
plus résiliente possible c'est-à-dire
qu'ils s'adaptent de plus en plus ce
vis-à-vis du réchauffement climatique et
pour ça il faut une agriculture près
diverses il faut développer les
écosystèmes il faut développer la soul
man il faut développer la rotation des
cultures voyez l'agroécologie c'est
quand même une agriculture justement qui
n'utilise pas de pesticides qui
n'utilise pas d'eau gm qui est qui est
une agriculture si vous voulez qui est
très équilibré et qui joue sur la
diversité l'agriculture intensive quand
je vous parle des lobbys ils sont
derrière qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ils
veulent qu'on achète encore le plus
intrants ils veulent qu'on achète encore
le plus de pesticides
ils veulent des semences justement que
c'est les gros
ce mancier qui vous vendent des semences
c'est ça qui les interdictions de
réutiliser ses propres graines pour
replanter dans les années suivantes par
exemple parce que si vous achetez ces
graines là vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de les replanter l'année
suivante alors vous demande vous
réclamez un vous le disiez la fin des
pesticides à vous souligner le fait que
notamment l'exposition aux pesticides
c'est une menace pour l'environnement
mais également pour les droits humains
alors pour l'environnement on le voit
bien mais est ce que vous pourriez nous
expliquer en quoi ça en quoi ça concerne
le droit humain eh bien je vais vous
prendre un exemple vous savez comment
j'ai un combat depuis des années sur ya
une centaine de pesticides interdits en
europe mais ils sont pas interdits de
fabrication et d'exportation alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe le lobby
justement des pesticides les lobbys de
la chimie et bien puisque c'est interdit
en europe ils vont l'exporter en
amérique du sud maromme le brésil c'est
un des pays qui utilisent le plus de
pesticides interdits ou en afrique sauf
que les gens ils n'ont pas la
connaissance et non pas la protection
pour l'utilisation de ces pesticides et
même par exemple on le sait au brésil il
utilise les pesticides pour chasser les
peuples autochtones et les droits
humains c'est à dire que il ya une telle
pression qui se fait à l'heure actuelle
pour alimenter par exemple les élevages
industriels de tourteaux de soja qui
viennent de ces pays là qui dit sont en
train de détruire la forêt amazonienne
est très souvent on a vu carrément des
hélicos qui balance et les pesticides
sur les villages de ces peuples
autochtones
donc oui ça joue sur l'environnement
parce que ça entraîne des maladies ça
entraîne des mots mais aussi sa chasse
les ces populations qui tombe malade et
qui sont obligés de partir et ils ont de
moins en moins d espace vital d'ailleurs
maintenant pour faire en sorte à ce
qu'ils puissent vivre ce que je voulais
dire tout à l'heure quand je vous disais
que les lobbys joue un rôle incroyable
de désinformation par rapport à cette
crise en ukraine il est où le problème
on a vu je vous ai dit il n'y a pas de
problèmes de production mais surtout ce
qu'il faut bien savoir c'est que les
élevages industriels utilisent la
plupart baisse real qui viennent
d'ukraine et de russie pour l'élevage
intensif et nous on dit l'élevage
intensif quand on parle par exemple des
bovins eh bien il faut qu'ils reviennent
au niveau de la terre c'est quoi ces
élevages ont très peu de temps on
augmente le voyez la proportion de la
viande et second tours d'ailleurs pour
l'exporter n'ont même pas pour
l'utiliser et ça nous utilisent voyez
ces terres là et puis la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de terre qui
sont utilisés pour l'agro carburant que
ça soit le bio de diesel ou le
bioéthanol il vaut mieux utiliser ses
hectares pour produire vous voyez des
aliments et non pas du bio est un homme
du bio est-il donc si on veut augmenter
la production même si on rentre dans
leur logique et bien diminué ces
agrocarburants pour faire vraiment de
l'alimentation pour les humains vous
pensez que l'europe sur ce sujet les
hypocrites je pense qu'elle est
hypocrite parce que elle nous tient des
discours très bien moi de la ferme à la
fourchette j'ai trouvé ça super
quand elle parlait aussi de ça sera
quand même une législation sur le zéro
pesticide le zéro substances toxiques
donc vous voyez éliminer les
cancérogènes mutagènes perturbateurs
endocriniens et puis quand on voit la
loi sur la santé et l'impact sur la
santé bien sûr et quand on voit la
réalité bon il ya un souci il ya une
crise de suite c'est les mesures
environnementales et sanitaires quand
qu'on balance vous voyez bien que ça
tient pas la route pensait que la
transition écologique telle qu'on la
souhaite avec l'objectif en 2050 et
nabeul avec les sanctions et parents qui
sont conjointes actuellement envers la
russie et ce qui se passe en ukraine
avait de toute façon bien sûr que les
tonnages et qu'elle est souhaitable et
puis on n'a pas bien de choix parce que
si on veut sortir des intrants
si on veut s'en sortir des engrais
chimiques
il va falloir développer l'agro écologie
agroforesterie voyez c'est ce type de
culture où il ya un très bon rendement
d'ailleurs mais c'est vrai que hausser
un peu l'abandon des monocultures c'est
l'abandon de l'agro tout ce qui est à
gros carburant etc et puis c'est revenir
à plein de petites exploitations
vous voyez où c'est beaucoup moins
digitalisées puisque voyez l'europe alde
il faut digitalisées numérisés et c'est
comme si c'était la panacée mais il faut
revenir aux bases et je pense que si on
veut sortir de la crise si on veut
sortir aussi des plats problématique du
dérèglement climatique
il faut qu'on soit sur les peu de plus
petites exploitations que on ait une
diversité de semences quand on applique
si vous voulez la pluralité des cultures
pour augmenter les écosystèmes et c'est
comme ça qu'on peut se passer des
pesticides
sa demande mais je vous dis une rotation
des cultures et sa demande il peut y
avoir des cultures par exemple qui
enrichissent la terre en nitrates alors
qu'à l'heure actuelle le modèle de
l'agriculture intensive et d'ailleurs le
rapport du giec lumens sortir le 10 il
ya un appauvrissement des terres de plus
en plus fort alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire mais il faut toujours mettre d
emblée le rapport jack ne parle pas que
de l'europe il parle du monde est belle
le modèle qu'on peut développer en
europe on peut le développer dans le
monde entier d'ailleurs c'est qu'on peut
l'imposer aux pays du monde à berne
afrique par exemple quand vous voyez les
pays et notamment la ffa ol dit il faut
développer l'agro écologie le même musée
parle de trois ans pour retourner là
pour inverser le réchauffement
climatique on pensait qu'en trois ans
peut l'imposer au monde entier mais
coûteux en afrique il ya beaucoup de
petites exploitations agricoles donc là
c'est pas le pire le pire c'est en
europe ou alors on a choisi un modèle
hyper intensifs ou plus vous avez des
hectares plus vous touchez diffusant sur
la pac ça vous voyez que les écologistes
ont voulu vraiment balancer ce système
on n'est pas arrivé mais il va falloir
qu'on y arrive oui je trouve que on est
vraiment une phase de changement de
modèle sont se dit on se donne les
moyens ça va être dur c'est dur de
changer on préfère continuer sauf que là
on augmente les inégalités on appauvrit
la terre voyez on a plus de pratiquement
d'oiseaux ont rien n'a pratiquement plus
d'insectes les pollinisateurs
disparaissent donc il nous amène au mur
c'est le sens de la mort oui à
l'agriculture intensive est alors sous
n'importe quel prétexte maintenant
ah non mais ça c'est écolo c'est c'est
du rêve c'est de l'utopie non c'est le
développement de la vie très bien merci
beaucoup michèle rivasi d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputés et membre du groupe des
verts alliance libre européenne
sous drop
plus de la moitié des habitants de
l'union européenne sont en surpoids on
retrouve à présent corentin alonso avec
son invité c'était à l'occasion du
colloque organisé par le collectif
national des associations d'obèses
je suis avec anne baigner bonjour
bonjour
experte auprès d'adam protection sociale
auprès de la commission européenne
vous avez participé au colloque
pré-présidentielle 2022 organisée par le
collectif national donc des associations
d'obèses le cn aof
en termes de politique européenne sur
l'obésité ou est-ce qu'on en est
actuellement qu'est ce qui a été fait
ces cinq dernières années
sur la politique de l'obésité de la
santé on va dire plus de manière
générale on a une grande disparité au
niveau européen vous avez des pays comme
les pays baltes ou la croatie qui sont à
65 % de personnes en surpoids la france
comme l'italie sont les derniers pays
donc les mieux positionnés puisqu'on a
que 40 7% jeudi que or taken déjà énorme
47 % de personnes en surpoids mais comme
8 millions de personnes obèses en france
roule bien le signaler
la santé donc n'est pas une compétence
de l'union européenne elle vient en
soutien des pays donc là je tiens à
souligner notamment le nouveau programme
européen au forceps qui a vu son budget
donc augmenter donc par qui a été
multiplié par vingt bon donc on est à
plus de 9 milliards aujourd'hui ce qui
est assez conséquents notamment en
matière de dépistage et le dépistage on
en a parlé pendant le colloque de
l'obésité est très important donc bon le
l'union européenne vient en renfort des
pays ou alors à des actions comme
le nude triste score mais là encore ça
prend des fois du temps parce qu'il faut
qu'on se mettre d'accord entre nous
entre tous les états membres donc c'est
ça qui est très complexe et c'est pour
ça que j'avais à coeur de venir
participer parce que donc on avait
moi même j'avais été investigatrice de
l'industrie score quand j'étais ok bien
ministériel donc c'est vrai que il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire mais
la france est plutôt bien positionné
mais c'est ce que j'ai dit attention qu
on ne reste pas sur nous zaki d'être
bien positionné et de continuer à
avancer sur le sujet de l'obésité
également au niveau européen et par
rapport à nos voisins qui sont très mal
positionné comme je l'aï dit j'ai dit
vous êtes intervenu dans la table ronde
qui parlait du manifeste du cnao alors
justement donc avec vous plusieurs
docteurs professeur présidents
d'associations
qu'est ce qui est faisable aujourd'hui
dans le manifeste du cna où ils ont
réclamé une prise en charge 100 % pour
les patients obèses est-ce qu'on peut
aller aussi loin ou est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des blocages au niveau européen on
peut aller on peut reconnaître l'obésité
comme pathologie chronique et on a aidé
ça c'est tout à fait possible on l'a
reconnu et je le déplore par la voie
parlementaire l'endométriose il ya
quelques il ya quelques mois de ça
normalement c'est aux autorités
sanitaires de reconnaître je trouve ça
dommage d'attendre
l'obésité reconnu fin et par tous les
spécialistes du sujet comme une maladie
les a aidés permettrait de le
reconnaître on a eu l'idée de leur
permettrait donc un meilleur
accompagnement un meilleur suivi du
patient une meilleure formation aussi
des professionnels qui ne maîtrisent pas
totalement des fois le sujet d'obésité
on le voit encore comme un sujet de
manger moins faire plus d'activité
physique or cela n'a rien avoir du tout
en réalité donc une prise en charge par
les ailes des de toute façon on va dire
des 500000 personnes qui vont être
touchés par cette obésité dite sévère un
moment donné vont déclarer un autre une
autre pathologie chronique qui vont
forcément les faire rentrer dans le
système a élevé donc pour moi ce serait
plus une façon de prévenir et de mieux
accompagner la personne en qui vieillit
victimes nous visiter au final parce que
vous êtes victime ce n'est pas de votre
faute d'être obèse donc ce serait
vraiment pour moi une manière de
prévenir encore plus vite la prise en
charge de ce patient zone europe s'est
terminée vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission un podcast audio et vidéo sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensations et aussi sur tv soixante dix
et rendez vous la semaine prochaine
bonne soirée
sonne robe sûr sensation
[Musique]